ja also was mir große sorgen bereiten
sind die tech konzerne ihre übermacht
ihre monopolmacht weil sie vergrößern
immer mehr die wirtschaftliche
ungleichheit die zersetzen die
gesellschaft und sie stellen eine gefahr
für die demokratie dar mit ihren
algorithmen und ihren daten
programmieren sie unser gehirn und
unsere verhaltensweisen und sie greifen
immer mehr in unser leben ein zum teil
mehr als regierungen ohne dafür
demokratisch legitimiert zu sein
deswegen plädiere ich für eine
entmachtung und zwar durch eine
verkleinerung durch regulierung
gesetzgebung
aufsicht besteuerung
haftungsvorschriften ja und einiges
andere um die ein bisschen an die leine
zu nehmen und nur wie die da habe ich
direkt eine frage sie haben donald trump
sehr hart kritisiert jetzt kritisieren
sie die tech konzerne sehr hart twitter
hat beispielsweise den us-präsidenten
dem ehemaligen us-präsidenten von seiner
plattform verbannt ist das richtig ist
das gesund für eine demokratie ja das
war in diesem fall richtig jetzt kommen
sie aber natürlich direkt mit einem
absoluten extrem sonderfall das kann man
noch mal separat diskutieren ich würde
mich jetzt mal so auf das konzentrieren
was uns alle betrifft unsere
gesellschaft unseren zusammenhalt und
und die wirtschaftliche ungleichheit ich
glaube das ist zunächst mal wichtiger
wenn wir das abgearbeitet haben dann
können wir zu den spezial problemen
kommen aber donald trump hat ja gewalt
angebracht werden das am 6 januar
gesehen und der mann ist wirklich
brandgefährlich wenn jemand darf
volksverhetzung betreibt muss man das
ein bisschen also dann haben wir ein
ganz spezielles phänomen ich fühle mich
persönlich sehr unwohl wenn twitter und
facebook plötzlich darüber entscheiden
was gefährlich ist was politiker was ja
auch zum teil gewählte gut donald trump
hat nicht gewonnen aber wurde ihnen von
fast 50 prozent der bevölkerung gewählt
wenn twitter darüber entscheidet ob
diese menschen sprechen dürfen oder
nicht aber das kommt ja auch daher dass
sie nicht generell reguliert sind sie
konnten ja eigentlich erst so groß und
so mächtig werden weil sie nicht
reguliert waren weil sie in keine box
gepasst haben keine vorschrift war auch
sie anwendbar das war eigentlich ein
wahnsinns wettbewerbsvorteil weswegen
sie auch so destruktiv tätig sein
konnten und andere
industrien branchen abhängen konnten
aber andere branchen die fantastisch
funktioniert funktioniert nehmen wir die
luftfahrt zum beispiel die war
profitabel für die
luftfahrtgesellschaften konnten billig
fliegen und es ist ganz selten ein
flugzeug abgestürzt die luftfahrt war
nicht immer profitabel für deutschland
also die luftfahrt branche in
deutschland würde ich jetzt nicht
profitabel okay aus sagt jetzt nochmal
ganz grundsätzlich aber es geht vor
allen dingen darum dass die sehr stark
was die sicherheit angeht und dem
verbraucherschutz reguliert waren und
selten flugzeuge abgestürzt sind sie
konnten trotzdem ganz gut wirtschaftlich
operieren und die tech konzerne haben
praktisch überhaupt keine vorschriften
die sie irgendwie im zaum halten und das
ist in keinerlei interesse von uns weil
das verringert den wettbewerb und
geringerer wettbewerber bedeutet im
endeffekt dann irgendwann höhere preise
geringere löhne für die menschen die
dort arbeiten und sie haben die absolute
preis macht das heißt letztendlich
müssen wir alle drauf zahlen also ich
bin ja auch sehr sehr wie sie vermutlich
ja wie sie auch freien wettbewerb und
gegen monopole gegen der pole ich frage
mich nur wie soll so eine entmachtung
von statten gehen weil man ein gesetz
schaffen das eine maximale höhe an
umsatz an börsenwert an angestellten
definieren will also soll der staat
wirklich die eigentümer sind ja die
aktionäre großteils enteignen soll der
staat dann gewissermaßen ein eine
oberaufsicht über die produkte anführen
die ganze angeboten werden also ich sehe
dort schon große schwierigkeiten wenn
sie sagen entmachten wäre das einfach
jetzt eine eine entkernung sozusagen
also eine zerschlagung des dass auch der
aktionäre oder wie soll man die
entmachten im rahmen einer
marktwirtschaft jeder andere industrie
ist reguliert ob wir die pharmaindustrie
nehmen die lebensmittelindustrie das
problem ist dass sie jetzt schon zu groß
geworden sie sind eigentlich zum teil zu
groß um sich selbst zu managen die schau
mir selbst kaum noch durch facebook
möchte gegen hate speech vorgehen also
gegen volksverhetzung und solche dinge
sie kommen mit ihren algorithmen selbst
kaum noch hinterher und sie erinnert
mich sehr an die finanzindustrie von vor
zehn zwanzig jahren die auch immer einen
schritt voraus war und die nachher
produkte geschaffen hat die sie selbst
bereichert haben und im endeffekt musste
die gesellschaft dann den schaden zahlen
als ungarn mal was daneben ging und so
ist auch die tech-branche jetzt so
speziell das kann man nicht selbst
ingenieur ist und diese algorithmen
verstehen kann kommt man kaum noch
hinterher das heißt das ist ein echtes
problem aber deshalb sollte man es jetzt
natürlich noch nicht aufgeben und diese
produkte funktionieren ja ehrlich gesagt
auch am besten wenn man sie so benutzt
dass sie eigentlich am schädlichsten
sind brandbeschleuniger absolut also
wenn man sich mal anschaut was auf
facebook abgibt in kommentarspalten wenn
man sich anschaut wie sich menschen auch
auf youtube radikalisieren und die
algorithmen immer neue inhalte
vorschlagen die natürlich auch alle in
dieselbe kerbe schlagen da wird es auch
einem unheimlich selbst wenn man sich
als als liberaler begreift eigentlich
die freie marktwirtschaft
betrachtet aber man hat das gefühl dass
es überhaupt keine möglichkeit gibt
einzugreifen weil wir sie auch sehr
treffend sagen die konzerne selbst gar
nicht sehen weil es so eine masse an
menschen so eine masse an daten gibt
fotos videos kommentare die hochgeladen
werden soll da habe ich ein ganz
spannender punkt und zwar immer wenn ich
irgendwas hochladen auf instagram zum
beispiel kommt immer und selbst nur als
volt corona stehen kommt der korona
warnhinweis wirklich bin ich hab schon
ausprobiert dass ich irgendwie ein wort
weglassen und da nicht dieser balken
über meinem posting kommt kommt immer da
frage ich mich fühle wenn die das so
sensitiv können vielleicht wollen sie
auch gar nicht jeder hate speech in dem
warnhinweis machen weil wenn das möglich
ist ich habe wirklich viele varianten
schon ausprobiert um nicht immer diesen
button dazu kriegen dann können sie
vielleicht auch hat es aber leider ein
brandbeschleuniger hat ist er fast eine
größere emotion als liebe und genauso in
kommentaren geht es mehr los
dementsprechend glaube ich manchmal das
metall so nennt sicherheits facebook
vielleicht auch gar kein interesse hat
komplett 1 von lee network zu werden ich
das und das glaube ich auch beim punkt
corona nur ganz kurz da sind die
offenbar tatsächlich sehr gut darin zu
erkennen und dann auch zu warnen jan so
haben die oft auch einfach vor absolut
legitime dingen gewartet nehmen wir
einmal die labor theorie also die frage
kommt krone aus dem labor und wo hahn
das sagen relativ viele experten
wissenschaftler darauf gibt es hinweise
das wurde von facebook konsequent über
monate hinweg gelöscht dann haben die
das entfernt diese regeln haben sich
haben um verzeihung gebeten aber das
wissenschaftliche stände
wissenschaftliche debatten zensiert
werden von einem unternehmen das ist
doch wahnsinn naja ich also ich gebe
ihnen erst mal grundsätzlich mache die
selbst diese krank machen einem angst
aber ich habe ein bisschen sorge dass
wissen sie wir haben in deutschland zu
erschweren ganz tapferen anwalt
steinhöfel er ist einer der wenigen der
sich mit facebook und auch youtube und
all diesen diesen tech konzern in
deutschland anlegt wenn mandanten von
ihm gesperrt werden und den kann man nun
nachlesen der zum block und der hat
nicht mal eine adresse eine zuständige
wo er ein deutsches urteil an youtube
oder facebook zu stellen kann er muss
dann nach irland gehen was enorme
verzögerung und auch enormen nachteils
für seine mandanten bedeutet und unsere
politik hier in deutschland kriegt das
nicht mal hin facebook und youtube oder
wie es meter dazu zu verdonnern freunde
zu schnell fähige anschrift bitte ab
morgen in deutschland deswegen sie haben
völlig recht ich fürchte es viel zu spät
er ist muss von der politik kommen und
was sie angesprochen haben ist ein
aspekt aber schauen wir uns viele andere
an zum beispiel amazon die dringend vor
in jedem lebensbereich von uns es ging
mal an mit büchern und dann kommerz und
jetzt gehen sie in amerika zumindest
information so sind praktisch
online-apotheken sie wollen
finanzdienstleistungen anbieten seit
jahren greifen sie alle unsere daten ab
sie wissen vor dem menschen selbst wie
jung sie sind wie alt sie sind sind sie
schwanger schwul was auch immer haben
diese daten silo übergreifend und haben
damit er auch ein und unter dem einsatz
der künstlichen intelligenz die immer
weiter immer schneller von sich selbst
lernt dh die haben einen so großen
wettbewerbsvorteil dass sie alle
konkurrenten die hoch kommen könnten vom
markt verdrängen können oder sie kaufen
sie auf entweder um sie zu integrieren
oder um sie abzuwickeln das heißt unter
den behandlungs kunden doch gott gedacht
nein das ist nicht okay weil sie erst
unterbieten sie alle preislich weil sie
natürlich an viel günstigen preis
anbieten können sie können hier viel
größere mengen abnehmen so dann kaufe
ich erst billig oder nehmen wir über
diesen fahrdienst in new york war super
beliebt war extrem preiswert wie können
die dann so preiswert diesen service
anbieten bis sie die hälfte der
taxifahrer aus dem business gekegelt
haben und schwupps dann gingen die
preise auf einmal ich muss leider reicht
es ist schon wieder vorbei vielen dank
die zugeschaut haben uns schön abend
noch bis morgen abend
schön abend
[Musik]